et maintenant mamie 12 me battre mais
mon sport même ici oui si fort si
l'implant géant dormant
j'ai rarement bonsoir
comment ça marc darmon
ça y est
c'est pas faux mais c'est vrai que
l'idée d'un passe temps là
e
et une demie
on me dit c'est un darmenton une autre
annonce on me dit qu'il faut refaire
l'entrée de gérard savat qu'est ce que
t'es baudillon merci non mais c'est fou
tu es attendu quel âge pour être si
baugé ravan serrées de l'année s'est
plus en plus beau ça incroyable gentil
non mais c'est vrai tu après l'émission
tu viens dîner avec moi s'il te plaît au
moins gérard qu'elle est très balayée
par la vie comme tu dis comme ça ça te
va bien tu sais j'ai yassa
mais oui regardez c'est vrai nom c'est
vrai il ya une vraie gueule les beaux
d'armand là ok bien alors tu vas le celi
je t'ai vu faire le mariole avec 3
gonzesses avec les mêmes lunettes bleues
là comme ça là un il y avait une qui
tandis qu'alizé il vachement bien votre
disque gérard darmon elle appelait ça
c'est beau une ville la nuit tomba alors
que ça s'appelle au milieu de l'année
quelle bonne voie la musique heures à la
base où l on parle informations de
journaux
tu as fait un disque b oui son meilleur
dans l'est sérieusement moi c'est mon
mail sur magna
non mais ça arrive en tête dîner avec
sinatra oui ou dans un petit restaurant
italien dans le xvème c'est fou
honnêtement pour ces derniers mais c'est
à quelle occasion
ils passent ils passaient à paris j'ai
joué était présente et je me suis
faufilé oui j'étais où il fallait être
et je me suis acoquiné mais aussi à le
vous êtes parlez vous oui il va faire un
jack daniel's une petite kamel sans
filtre se fait déjà deux marques des
premières 3 il paraît jeudi jack penate
a fait un disque il va subir très bon
dit son meilleur album pour moi écouter
un peu comment il chante le vermont
ce n'est pas sûr
oco
je
à
j'ai cette possible alors je veux
quelque part
gérard darmon si c'était possible donc
extrait de son album comment mieux sur
lci
c'est beau
dans le milieu de la nuit on me dit que
ce n'était pas la bonne vitesse fort pas
souhaité trop peu un peu un peu tape est
parce que là il ya deux barytons karama
qui parle ça va a des couilles mais bien
mérité jaurès parler
à
bien gérard prend les choses à zéro 1 0
à 2 0 déjà non il ya toujours baigné
dans la musique en fait depuis que que
vous étiez tout petit tu as toujours
baigné dans la musique quand le quand tu
étais petit vous écoutiez andré claveau
georges ulmer j'écoutais ce qu'avaient à
la radio et j'ai écouté des surtout du
rail 1 parce que avant que le rail
arrivant au défèrement ensuite il une
shon beatles évidemment comme tous les
gens de valeur génération gerra et puis
la black music aussi stevie wonder tout
ça donc il a eu envie de chanter
toujours et est en fait nous l'avait
jamais fait vous aviez fait votre deuil
de l'idée de chanter tout petit peu
proposé de faire des coups en fin des
coups mais voilà on va faire des trucs
over une grosse voix avec des chats est
là derrière ça me disait trop rien moi
si je me suis si un jour doit le faire
je veux faire un album que je puisse
écouter un avec mes potes qui me regarde
dans les yeux hagards dans leurs
chaussures la maison c'est une daube je
sais pas comment on lui dira donc
j'avais envie que ce soit un peu enfin
j'avais envie de faire un truc que
j'aime et le faire jusqu'au bout
c'est ce qui m'est alors donc vous aviez
fait un petit peu votre deuil de l'idée
de faire un album jusqu au jour où
philippe abitbol vous dit un type de
chez sony ont envie de te faire chanter
voilà mais c'est exact il n'y a rien à
ajouter c'est une histoire vraie il a
fait cette remarque on n'a pas
comptabilisé babybel de tout à l'heure
l'a5 alors flexipan
alors l'écriture ça va d'henri salvador
lansman roda-gil c'est vraiment la
vieille garde à la nouvelle garde c'est
à dire bénabar sanseverino mickey 3d et
ce qui est extraordinaire si vous êtes
arrivé à éviter obispo et vehlmann
non mais c'est vrai oui mais c'est à
dire c'était pas le c'était pas le but
quoi j'aurais très bien pu j'ai très
bien pu aller les bras mais je voulais
pas je voulais pas faire cette musique
ce genre de musique là qui ils le font
très bien ce formidable les gens je peux
l'écouter aussi c'est pas c'est pas le
propos j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
norman bis pour je le connais il n'ya
pas n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de date
est bien décrite comme ça j'adore ces
craintes et les couilles pour conjurer
le sort
c'est physique quantique est ce que tu
veux savoir ce que je veux dire non mais
voilà tu fais une entrée directement
dans la chanson française je trouve que
c'est vrai que bénabar et tout ça c'est
pas mal ils ont repris le flambeau d'une
certaine chanson des traditions
françaises je suis pas toujours tout
d'accord avec leur musique est ce qu'ils
écrivent j'aime ce qu'ils écrivent le
thème de l'album c'est l'amour 1
l'amour les amours les désamour l'amour
multiforme moi l'amour les coups de
blues les coups de foudre
les rencontres le quotidien vatan
reviens je t'aime pourquoi pas les
sentiments une grande place dans ton
disque les sentiments une grande place
dans on dissout et pourrait développer
c'est complètement autobiographique
c'est tout voilà oui enfin ça n'aurait
aucun intérêt si ce n'était qu'au taux
biographiques et ce qu'est ce qui est
drôle c'est que si tu les coûts tout si
on écoute laon puis son pis ça puisse
raisonner et qu'on puisse trouver
quelque chose de d'un peu universel et
ya rien de plus sinon tu vas nous le
faire réécouter c'est vachement même